I do want to take a few moments and
speak with Cassandra Spencer former U.S
army public affairs officer turned
Facebook Insider turned project Veritas
undercover journalist her work has
generated millions of views on social
media and she's got the scoop for us
Cassandra thank you so much for being on
the show thanks for having me Michael
what the heck is going on over at
project fairy task
I have to tell you when I saw this I was
absolutely shocked
um I had been talking back and forth
with James you know right after the
Pfizer thing and I was like this is the
biggest story you know Veritas has ever
done this is incredible work
and so to all of a sudden hear that he's
been put on paid leave
and that there's a board meeting today
to vote on his fate as being the CEO of
the company was absolutely shocking to
me
and then to read what the actual
allegations are from the employees that
were sent to the board it was even more
shocking not only the contents but who
was saying it
so the the accusations as far as I can
read are that James O'Keefe is a tough
guy to work for and he makes you work
long hours and I saw one one accusation
this was the most damning accusation I
saw was that he he ate an employee's
sandwich one time or something which you
know not best practices in the office
but we've all kind of done it you know
in the company fridge so this this just
seems so bogus to me
what do you think is actually a play
here
I honest I can't get to the bottom of
that but it does seem and it's not the
first time in Project veritas's history
where there has been
um competing forces within the company
who want to see the company go in One
Direction or another in fact I was
caught up in one such
thing completely by accident by being
the first whistleblower who had gone to
project Veritas several years ago
and I think that's what's going on now
because as you said the the accusations
are kind of just silly yes James O'Keefe
is a very tough boss
um that doesn't mean he's a bad boss
right
some of the best bosses I've ever worked
for can are really really tough and they
they get good work out of you so what
are the directions that people want to
take it in because in my mind I read
that they want to boot James O'Keefe out
of project Veritas I thought what is
Project Veritas without James O'Keefe I
I don't mean that just in a way to
defend James I I simply thought these
two things are synonymous it'd be like
taking Trump out of Maga what is that
Maga is the Trump movement if he goes
away then there's some other movement I
guess but but this other faction in
Project Veritas what sort of people are
they and where do they want to take the
organization
it's very strange to me when I look at
the people who signed the employee
letter
um and of course there's also been media
reports of certain board members
um the one board member in question
who's been mentioned in some of these
Twitter threads every interaction I ever
had with him was fantastic so frankly I
was very surprised to see his name
um being mentioned in regards to this
but I will say that a lot of the people
who talk about you know maybe salacious
things that have happened at project
Veritas some of the people in those
letters really should be examining
um their own behavior because
perhaps those in glass houses shouldn't
be throwing stones
uh that is a very diplomatically stated
Cassandra I wonder
you know will there be a real
International fight here you know you're
suggesting the people making these
accusations have personal problems of
their own how ugly is this going to get
I hope that it doesn't get ugly I truly
hope that maybe this was something you
know James can get stressed out and
Moody like any other human being he's a
person
so I'm hoping that maybe this was
something like hey James maybe you're
taking it a little too far being too
hard on people right now in this moment
and you need to take a step back
I'm hoping that's all this is do you
think it's in response to Pfizer though
I mean do you think it's the timing is a
little bit weird so is it simply that
the Pfizer story a very stressful story
biggest thing project Veritas has ever
done and so James is just very stressed
out and people are reacting organically
and naturally to that or is it people
don't like the pro the project very
tough Pfizer story and there are forces
here at play and pressure coming perhaps
from Pfizer perhaps from other places to
try to force him out because of the
visor story
I would wait to see and we have
wonderful internet sluice out there to
see what the board members potential
connections are to Pfizer because it's
not something that I'm willing to rule
out as a possibility it's not something
that I'm immediately going to jump on
but as you said the timing is truly
bizarre because you don't normally think
to replace the CEO when you're winning
right and when you get the biggest
victory in your company's history it
just it just raises a lot of red flags
for me I'm not even all that close with
James it's I've always I've always liked
him I've always really liked his work I
just don't know him that well and and so
as a mostly an outsider here I looked at
this I said ah something seems up the
timing here is a little bit weird this
is an incredible such an important
conservative story I just don't trust
the people trying to push him out uh
Cassandra I gotta let you go there thank
you so much for coming on and shedding a
little bit of light on the situation
where can people find you uh you can
find me on Twitter Cassandra Spencer
minus the last e in my name because Elon
wouldn't let me have enough characters
we got a Lobby Elon we gotta listen
increase the limit of the handles thank
you Cassandra for coming on
thank you
[Music]